ll right, let's go to the phones and see what
is on people's minds at 6 1 7 8 3 0.
Forty seven fifty starting today with our
caller from the 2 1 6 area code caller from
2 1 6.
What's your name?
Where are you calling from today?
Hi, David.
I'm Carter.
I'm calling from Cleveland.
Hey, Connor, what's up?
So I was listening to a Facebook livestream
from Heather Cox Richardson, a professor at
the Boston College.
Right.
She proposed to me.
Boy, Connor, you're breaking up, my friend.
You.
She proposed.
What?
You're breaking up.
She proposed.
How did McConnell know that Hillary wasn't
going to win when he blocked the nomination
of Merrick Garland?
But how did he know that Hillary wasn't going
to win?
Is it just luck or did he know something?
No, I don't.
I mean, listen, it's a gamble, right?
I mean, you might block it or you might not.
If you're a guy, get in, then Trump picks
the replacement.
It's not a guarantee.
I mean, it is it is the idea that it implies
some kind of rigged election or something
like that.
Butsome to be heard.
Oh, okay.
I mean, I haven't heard what she said, but
if you mean so if you say you if you block
this for a year, you might give the pick to
a Republican.
And if not, listen, you still deleted and
OK, Hillary gets to pick, but you at least
had a shot at it.
It doesn't to me say that something conspiratorial
necessarily happened.
Interesting, too.
The chances are that Biden would go ahead
and nominate Garland if he gets the chance.
I have absolutely no idea.
I do.
I don't get it.
I don't know that merit.
I mean, that was years ago.
I have no clue.
There's so many people that could be chosen
from I don't I've not heard anything about
Biden and Merrick Garland.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well.
All right, Connor, thank you very much, I
appreciate the call, certainly something to
think about.
Let's go next to our caller from the 5 1 0
area code who's calling today from 5 1 0.
Hey.
Hey, David.
This is Arash from California.
Hey, Arash, what's up?
Yeah.
So I kind of have a two part question.
Like, firstly, from my general understanding,
when it comes to like economic development
in third world countries, some of the like
a main contributing factors are like for growth
are like things like education, the infusion
of foreign capital, the transference of like
soft skills, like foreign technology.
With that in mind, do you think that the policy
that Paul Hughes involving forced technology
transfer like that is the practice in which
in which a domestic government requires foreign
businesses to share their tax less soft skills
in exchange for market access?
Is that is that a desirable thing for developing
countries with a large market?
Right.
And if that misses the second part.
Now, if it is a good thing, do you think that
the rise of multilateral critical trade agreements,
which give us a stronger protections against
FTT through the enforcement of intellectual
property rights and the ability to bring nations
to court, Investor-State Dispute Settlement
there, those the ability of those countries
to engage an FTT?
The answer to all of those questions is it
depends and it has to be looked at on a case
by case basis.
And it's that I'm not to be clear, I'm not
picking on you here when I say this or that.
But that's the exact type of question where
if you're looking for a yes or no answer,
you're essentially thinking about this the
wrong way.
Because there is the answers to those questions
would depend on what types of technologies
are we talking about?
Which countries are we talking about?
What are the underlying industries and employment
circumstances of those companies, of those
countries?
What currency is the prevailing reserve currency
in those countries?
And how does that relate to the country in
which the businesses they're looking to buy
operate?
There's no possible way that I could say yes,
that's good.
And no, it's not a concern about the the arbitration.
It's it's such a huge issue.
I don't see any simple answer to it.
Yeah, yeah, I guess I was thinking it from
the perspective of like one of the arguments
in favor of, for example, tariffs, right?
Yeah, that'd be insane.
In an industry argument.
Right.
So what could could there be like like specific
sectors, for example, like high skilled sectors,
like telecommunications or like stuff like
or like, you know, biotechnology and stuff
like that in which you could help facilitate
the development of these specific industries
through the FTT.
But that's what I love, of course.
Of course, that's certainly possible, but
it's not guaranteed.
And that's why this is the.
You just have to deal with really specific
examples, you know, multilateral trade deals.
Trump increasingly is talking about bilateral
trade deals as opposed to multilateral.
And a lot of his followers are just like,
yeah. Trump says it's good.
So that must be good.
It must be good because Trump, the big boy,
can negotiate directly or whatever.
For me, there's no hard and fast rule about
depending on which countries we're talking
about, depending on the scope of a particular
trade deal.
Multilateral may be more logical or it may
not be.
If you when looking at the supply chains,
for example, if you are in a country where
your supply chain for the areas that you're
looking to do a trade deal around are heavily
dependent on five other countries and you
want to do a bilateral trade deal with only
one of those countries.
That's a recipe ripe for creating new problems.
So maybe a multilateral deal is more appropriate
there.
In other cases where there is more direct
competition and it's more an issue of specialization
between two countries, maybe in that case
it's the bilateral trade deal that you need.
My point is everybody claiming to have the
definitive answer on a lot of this stuff is
is not looking at specific examples typically.
OK, well, good talking you, David.
Nice calling in for the show.
I appreciate the answer.
All right.
Appreciate the phone call, Arash.
Thank you.
Hope to hope to speak to you soon.